Hello world,
it's Saroj and ripple.
It's a digital currency designed
for banks. That's right.
I said for banks, not to
replace banks, but for bex,
and it's controversial,
but it's one of the highest market cap
current currencies out there in the space
right now.
So in this video,
I'm going to build a minimal ripple
client that acts as a wallet.
Here's an example.
Okay.
So what we can do with this client is we
can generate an identity just like this.
And uh, first I got to yet. So there's
our identity, it's 25 characters.
And then what we can do is we can connect
to the ripple network and then it's
going to say, okay, it connected
with the results success,
and then we can send payments,
uh,
by using the token Xrp to another address.
And that's it.
That's the only three
things we're going to,
we're going to code out to get a feel for
how the ripple API works in javascript.
So it's going to be a
simple web app like that.
But first we've got to talk about this
thing, right? How does this thing worked?
Is a decentralized, is it centralize?
What's the deal with ripple? Right?
So we're going to go into his history,
some of its features,
it's consensus protocol,
the Xrp token versus the Iou.
And then we're going to build this thing.
So first of all, Tldr, there's a lot,
there's a lot here. So all
the ripple tokens, the XRP
Tokens, they've been issued.
So you can't, uh, they can't meant
any more. They're not doing that.
There's no rewards for minors. All the
tokens have already been issued. Okay.
They'd been pre mind. And
it's not a blockchain. That's,
that's a very key point.
It's very similar to a blockchain,
but it's not a blockchain in that,
that transactions in the network aren't
grouped into these blocks and inside of
the blocks or the transactions in the
form of a Merkle Dag. No, no, no, no.
It's just one giant list.
Okay.
And every node in the network
maintains a copy of that list,
but it's not in the form of blocks that
are pointing to other blocks just to,
you know,
it's just a nit picky distinction that
I want to make before people say, oh,
it's a decentralized blockchain.
It's not a blockchain,
it's just a digital currency.
You could say it's a digital currency
made for banks and there are a group of
validater nodes and that's how
the network agrees upon, uh,
whether or not a transaction is valid.
So nodes will vote on a
set of validater nodes.
Like these are kind of like
senators in the U S Senate, right?
It's not like the u s is a
direct democracy where every
participant can vote on
every single law. No, we
elect in the u s we elect, uh,
what are called senators and then they
make all the decisions for us and we
trust them. So it's not
decentralized. It's not completely,
it's not completely centralized.
It's somewhere in the middle,
nearing towards centralized. But I'm
going to talk more about that. So, um,
and, and these validators aren't
earning any rewards for validating these
transactions. They're just doing this
because a out of goodwill and be,
because only that validater
nodes can make, uh,
can vote on changes to the protocol.
So they get voting rights in
that way to the protocol. Oh,
there's also this idea of a gateway and,
uh,
basically any business can register as
a gateway and then you can create your
own issuances. So if I'm a business and
I have like, let's say I'm an airline,
I can register as a gateway and the
ripple network, and then I have some,
you know, miles or bonus points
or something, people can pay me,
say a thousand US dollars and then I can
send them a thousand bonus points and
ripple will facilitate that transaction,
that exchange between currencies.
And a lot of banks are using
this right now. But, uh,
the main use of Xrp as a,
as a token is to pay for transaction fees.
That that's why it exists.
And when you pay the fee,
the XRP is our burnt and then destroyed.
So the total number of XRP
existing become smaller every day.
That was just the Tldr. Before I go into
all of this, okay, so back to the history.
So, uh, payments online. So http,
http as a protocol basically made a
communicating with people online globally,
instantly, right? So globally you could
communicate with anyone online instantly,
but the same kind of innovation did not
apply to the payment space because we
had already created this kind of network
of pre internet protocols like Ach,
swift,
et cetera.
And banks had different relationships
with each other and this was kind of
tacked onto the http web,
but it was still slow, right?
Certain banks had to have
relationships with other banks.
Here's a little bit of
discrete math for you.
If you think about the common editorial
complexity of a problem where I'm a bank
and I want to send you money
and you're a bank, however,
we don't have any direct relationship.
So what we're going to have to do is
we're going to have to go through this
chain of banks, right? And each bank
has a relationship with another bank,
common editorial laid.
This could be,
this could be an explosion in terms of
the complexity of how many different hops
the transaction has to go
through, right? But with ripple,
the idea was let's create a protocol for
these banks so they can transfer money
from one to the other directly.
Ripple really solves two main problems.
One instant transfers between
banks, right? So right now,
if I send money internationally
from bank a to Bank B,
that takes between three to five days.
But with ripple, if a bank uses this,
then you could send money instantly
and to the second problem is lower
transaction fees,
right?
So how can we make this transaction
happen with the lowest costs and for these
two problems?
Ripple actually does this very well.
I know ripple actually solve this
problem very well for banks. Okay?
There are some downsides in
terms of decentralization,
which I'm going to go into.
But you know,
bitcoin tried to solve this
problem of removing a bank, right?
So it's not like ripple and
bitcoin or competing in any way.
They're completely different
protocols. Bitcoin is, is, uh,
speculatory currency, right?
It's, it's made for speculation.
Really. It's it, yes,
it's a digital currency, but
no one's using bitcoin as
a currency. Let's be real.
Like bitcoin is a tool for speculation.
It's an asset class.
And we can use the blockchain as this
kind of global distributed ledger where we
can add all sorts of digitized
assets and timestamped things for,
you know, just proving that something
exists without needing a third party.
Smart contracts. There's a
bunch of functionality, but
we can't just say, you know,
no one's using bitcoin for it.
You know, day to day transactions.
It's too volatile. But it was
made for consumers, right?
From person a to person B send a
transaction without needing a bank.
Ripple is not like that to ripple is for,
for banks to send money
between each other.
And it was designed to eliminate bitcoins,
reliance on centralized
exchanges as decentral,
as decentralized as Bitcoin is,
you still,
if you want to exchange that
bitcoin into any other currency,
you got to go through one of
these centralized exchanges
like Coinbase or bits
stamp, et cetera. So with ripple,
it supports payment in any type of
currency, whether that's cryptocurrency,
Fiat currency or any kind of, you know,
tokens that are not even currency,
like bonus points or miles or whatever
ripple is being adopted by a lot of banks.
It's being adopted by a lot of
governments, Bank of America,
HSBC bank in over 65 countries.
Japan is a major player in
ripple. Um, it's, it's like,
I think I read somewhere like
up to 40% of transactions in Ge,
in Japan in five years are going to be
using the ripple protocol in some way
because the banks in Japan are
adopting ripples so fast. But, uh,
I hear that. Here's this other image
of, you know, the ACH transfer process,
you know, US bank to Ubank,
whop, whop, whop, whop, whop,
whop. And then bitcoin is,
you know, direct to direct, however,
seven to 45 minutes for a transaction.
And then ripple is six seconds.
Okay, six seconds. Instant transfer.
So let's see here. Where are
we with ripple, right? Let's,
let's look at the coin
market capitalist here.
Ripple is for all time, right? This,
this thing has been around for four years.
It's just been kind of
chilling until recently. And
Boom, look at this explosion.
It is hot. It is hot right
now. The currency is hot.
And what drives the,
the prices of these cryptocurrencies?
Remember, it's speculation.
It's news and a lot of banks,
a lot of institutions are adopting ripple,
which is what, what, what, you know,
accounts for this, right? In the future.
More and more it's going to be
utility instead of speculation.
But right now it's mostly speculation.
Arguably ripple has a lot of utility.
That's why these banks are using
this right now in production.
Like real banks are using this protocol.
Uh,
but you know, it's not perfect.
Obviously it's not perfect.
It's a proof of concept.
And there are problems with,
they like one problem is when
it was founded, it, there
was a huge pre mine, right?
So 80 billion tokens were allocated
to the company and the Ripple Labs
Foundation and then 20 billion were
given to the three founders. Right? Um,
so today glow globally, banks are
connected through proprietary networks.
There's no open standard
for communication. Hence all
the hops between networks,
but ripple enables any bank to access any
bank on the network, uh, directly, right?
It costs about 0.04 a sense and
takes three to five seconds to send.
Whereas bitcoin take cost over 25 US
dollars sometimes and takes up to an hour.
So here at three features that I thought
were really useful for were really cool
about ripple. So the first feature are
the gateways feature. So for gateways,
the idea is this, so anyone can
register to become a gateway.
These are businesses that provide a way
for money and other forms of value to
move in and out of the Xrp Ledger,
right? So if I'm a, you know, a bank,
a bank can apply,
obviously it to be a gateway,
but a person can apply
to be a gateway as well.
So if I'm a person and
I've got to say USD,
and this dude is only going to
accept euro's, he's like, you know,
I worked for you and I deserve 500 euros.
And I'm like, okay, I've got, you know,
600 USD and I'm going to, but I don't
have heroes. I want to pay you. Right?
So I've got my bank,
you've got your bank in Europe,
I've got my bank in the u s and I'm
going to pay ripple will facilitate this
transaction by the use of water called
gateways. So the gateway is going to say,
I've got USD and I've got euro and you're
going to send money to me and then I'm
going to send money to him. Okay. And
so in the, in the middle of all of this,
we've got Xrp as a bridge
between all of these currencies,
right from USD to euro XRP
acts as that bridge currency.
And so what happens is the network
is going to work like this.
You propose a payment by
specifying the source,
you and the destination
accounts and the currencies.
The system gives you a quote
based on public offers.
There are these entities
called market makers,
and these are basically
anybody can be a market maker.
They'll do things like arbitrage,
but basically they'll profit off of
making buy and sell orders in the network
and they're basically making the market
by making these buy and sell orders.
So you'll say,
I want to make a transfer and here's the
maximum amount I'm willing to pay for
that transfer.
The market makers will have all these
buy and sell orders for all of these
different conversions and the network
will match you up with the best for your
threshold for what you're willing to pay.
Then the gateway will then facilitate
that transaction between you and the
destination using that buy or
sell order from the market maker.
The market maker will make
that transaction fee and
Xrp and the pain will go
through the gateway. It can go
through several gateways actually,
but it will get to the destination within
three to five seconds, six seconds,
seven seconds under 10 seconds for sure.
But it's a really fast,
a way to send money between banks,
right.
So there are different ways that gay,
there are different models
that gateways can follow.
You can have an issue in gateway,
a private exchange,
and merchants can accept the payments
in exchange for goods and services with
the outside world. So there's a lot of
different ways that you can be a gateway.
There's other feature I thought
was really cool, was not cool,
but just interesting. Uh, not
necessarily cool but interesting. That's,
that's a better word for this. But
the freezing balances feature. So, uh,
this was actually a very controversial
feature, but, and you know,
there's a lot of negative hype around
this that ripple gateways can freeze users
funds any time. This is true,
but there has to be some corn,
some kind of reason for that,
right?
So if you think about compliance
between all these different governments,
you know,
KYC compliance about it at a ripple was
made to facilitate transactions between
banks. And if you really want
to do something for banks,
banks are all about government compliance.
So any protocol they use
has to be compliant with
these, you know, governments,
right? So if a government needs
to, you know, freeze a transaction,
they see something illegal happening,
they need to reverse funds. They need to,
you know, whatever. There has to
be some way for them to do that.
So ripple allows for governments to then
freeze funds by seizing the whatever's
in the gateway, that intermediary to
prevent any kind of illegal transactions.
Now this is controversial and
a decentralized space, right?
Because this allows control
from governments and third
parties, right? So, but um,
that's, that's how it is.
And because it is compliant,
that's why its market
cap is rising so fast.
That's why that's why all these banks
are adopting it so fast because it's,
it is government compliance.
So yes,
the negative is that governments can
seize those funds if there is some illegal
transaction.
So there is some trust involved there.
Uh, but they can't seize XRP. So
that's the really key difference.
They can seize any currency
that the gateway is holding,
except for Xrp because that is a digital
currency. It is not a Fiat currency.
So these market makers,
anybody can be a market maker.
They can make a living off
of being a market maker.
But what they do full time
as they look for, you know,
buy and sell options and they
will hedge the on those options.
So they'll make some profit by saying,
you know, I've got x amount of currencies,
I've got y amount of this currency and
then I see this order, I'm going to,
you know, say I've got that and
then I'll get the transaction fee.
And it's just continually do that.
And this will be facilitated,
facilitated through the gateway.
So when it comes to consensus,
we can think of the network like
this. We've got two banks, right?
Bank a and Bank B and someone will send
money from bank a to bank B and it's
going to go through the ripple network.
These are the validator knows they're
going to validate all those transactions.
Market makers are going to,
are going to make buy and sell orders
to facilitate the exchange between these
currencies. It's a decentralized
exchange. Once it is approved,
it's going to go through a gateway and
then end up at the receiving end of the
bank. So, like I said, there is not a
blockchain. There's just a giant ledger.
Just think of it as an a giant excel
spreadsheets. And inside of this,
it's got the ledger number, account
settings, balances, transactions,
whether or not a transaction
was validated, all this
stuff. And every few seconds,
this giant list of transactions is updated
over time by the validater nodes as
new transactions are coming in,
right?
So ripple runs a network of servers.
Anybody can become a client's, right?
And at the heart of the network is this
ledger, it's a distributed database. Uh,
and so any server can introduce
a transaction to them network.
These transactions go out to all
active ripple servers and the servers
automatically come to consensus about a
set of transactions to apply it to the
ledger creating a new
closed ledger. So, but how,
how is it doing this?
Right?
So this is where the trust and the
kind of centralization comes in.
It's not completely decentralized.
Remember I said that from the start,
but the goal of consensus in ripple is
for each server to apply the same set of
transactions to the current ledger.
So every server is going to,
basically it's going to say how many
other a validater nodes have approved this
transaction.
So every or node is going to agree
whether on whether or not a transaction is
valid based on if other validater
nodes say it's a valid transaction.
So the validater nodes are trusting
their, the other validater notes, right?
So they are all trusting each other.
So there is some trust there and the
servers are continually receiving
transactions from other
servers in the network.
And basically every validator node is
polling the other validater nodes to see
if they have accepted a certain
transaction. And so it's, uh, it's,
it's going editor iteratively, right? So,
and so a server is going to receive
proposals from the other servers and the
network. A proposal is a set
of transactions to consider
applying to the ledger.
So they're going to propose, you
know, x amount of transactions.
These are all valid. Let me propose
that to all the other validater notes.
And the server only pays attention to
incoming proposals from the server set.
They're matched with the candidate
set. And if there is a, uh,
it at the server,
a server is going to take transactions
that have received at least a 50%
approval rating and package them into a
new proposal. And this goes iteratively,
that proposal goes out to other servers
in the network, the process repeats,
but this time it looks for a 60% approval.
The process repeats this
time a 70% approval.
And at that point the network
has reached consensus.
So there is trust involved amongst the
validater nodes with each other who in
turn are trusted by the network.
They are voted on by the network.
So there are two types
of payment methods here.
One is Xrp and then the other is an Iou.
So XRP is the native currency of ripple.
And anyone can accept Xrp,
they can send Xrp.
It takes care of cross
border transactions.
But there's also this concept of the Iou.
So IOUs are issued on the platform and
they are redeemable for a fungible asset
like USC or gold or whatever.
Anyone can issue these IOUs.
But in order for someone
to accept a payment,
they must trust that person who issued
them to be able to redeem the Iou for the
underlying assets.
So there is some trust involved and
mostly banks are using this IOU concept to
say, okay, you know, I
don't have the fun here,
but I'm going to promise that I'm
going to give this phone to you.
They'll accept that payment and then
hopefully the bank then sends that money.
So this is, there is this trust
involved, but it's faster. Okay,
so let's get to to building
this thing, right? So, uh,
let me open this up. Okay. So
in the index dot, html, uh,
I've got this basic html and all we're
going to do is we're in a code up the
Java script for, uh, showing, uh,
generating an identity in the network
and then connecting to the network and
then sending a payment. Three different
things, right? What each of these html,
these dom elements are doing are there,
they're using an on click,
an event listener to call these three
javascript functions that are using the
ripple, uh, Api, right?
So we've got press to generate an identity
press to connect to ripple and then
press to send a payment, right? So if
we go down here, here's the ripple,
a js library. Just, you know,
I'm just putting it in time
inside of this script, html tag.
We're just going to scroll down,
scroll down, scroll down, scroll down,
and then we'll get to the, to the part
where we can, you know, code this,
this part up the, the, the part
that matters here. Okay. So, um,
first to open in the opening set up,
I'm going to say,
here's my address. Uh, and
then I want the remote server,
which I'm going to initialize
using the ripple, uh,
object and instance of
the ripple a server.
And then in the servers I'm going to
use are these default servers right here
that, uh, I could have my own
server, I could use another server,
but luckily there's this
client, a globally that I'm
using, is using right here,
that ripple provides that I can use as a,
as a server to just connect to
directly. And then I can say, okay,
let me generates a, an identity.
So this is what's called,
whenever we say generate an identity.
So in this function I'll say take
the result of generate address,
which is a part of the ripple Api.
And then set the identity in the html
to whatever the result of that is.
And then set the secret,
my remote
server to the resulting
address. That's it. Okay.
Just like that. And now I'm going
to have the connect function.
So for the connect function, I'm going to
say connect, uh, connect to ripple. Okay?
So this is going to connect to the
ripple network, right? This is our very,
very simple minimalist client
that we're building here.
And we're going to use a remote
that we initialize before to say,
here is a callback function that's going
to return an error and the response,
and we're going to say
either the result,
their response,
or it's going to be successful,
whether or not it's successful,
do the following, get the outcome,
uh, and then, well,
we're going to say, okay,
connected to ripple so we can display
that in html, connect to ripple.
And then alert outcome,
right? Just like that.
And then lastly,
we're going to say,
send Xrp, right? So whenever we hit,
you know, sin, we're going to have,
we're going to specify an amount,
right? The amount of Xrp to destination.
And then we're gonna say,
okay, so take the transaction.
There's going to be,
we're going to use that same remote
object to create a transaction,
or it's going to ask for some,
it's going to ask for some, uh,
parameters. So we'll say, my address,
here's my address, the source,
here's the destination that I've
specified, destination. And then lastly,
we'll say, here's the amount, the
amount is whatever I specify it
right now I can say
transaction dot summit.
Here's my transaction. I've
initialized it as an, as an object.
And now I can submit that transaction.
It's going to be in the form
of a callback. Did it, was
it successful? Was it not?
This will tell us,
notify the outcome,
error response.
And that's just going to take the
result of that. Okay? So yeah,
those are three basic functions.
And then we can go back.
We can see the results here.
Uh, we can connect to ripple,
we can generate an identity,
we can send the payment.
I don't have any XRP in this wallet,
but it's very simple.
All the code for this is in the get
hub repo in the video description.
So definitely check it out.
I've got more detailed documentation
and instructions there,
so I hope you found this useful. Please
subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now I'm going to work on a
music video, so thanks for watching.